ivana trump has died she was 73 years
old
go ahead ivana was once married to
former president donald trump who
confirmed the news on social media ivana
and donald divorced in 1992 they shared
three kids together donald jr ivanka and
derek just the most beautiful children
in the world and you have to remember
the children always has worked out very
well between ivana and myself as far as
what happened it's assumed ivana died of
natural causes police responded to a
call of someone in cardiac arrest at
yvonne's apartment on thursday but
officials are still waiting on the new
york city medical examiner to determine
her cause of death in his message donald
writes ivano was a wonderful beautiful
and amazing woman who led a great and
inspirational life that life included
working various roles in the trump
organization writing books and launching
multiple jewelry and fashion lines i had
a very fashionable mother all the while
being an inspiration for her children
the jewelry is
my fun little escape so
my mother was the one who inspired that
in me this is what the life is about you
know everybody has a dream you know have
a children and raise the family and this
is what our society is all about eric
her youngest pays tribute on instagram
sharing these family photos and writing
our mother was an incredible woman she
taught her children about grit and
toughness compassion and determination
she will be dearly missed by her mother
her three children and 10 grandchildren
i have been doing very well and been
quite successful and very happy and so
there is a life before ex-husband and
there is a life after after happening
[Music]
you